يواجه تهمه جنائيه للمره الثانيه لاحتفاضه
بوثائق سريه في منزله في فلوريدا في الوقت
الذي يخطط العودته الى البيت الابيض وقبل
اقل من شهرين اصبح اول رئيس سابق في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده يواجه اتهامات جنائيه
بعدما صوتت هيئه محلفين كبرى في منهات
بتوجيه الاتهام اليه لدوره في دفع اموال
لاسكات ممثله الافلام الاباحيه
عشرات التهم تطارد ترامب تبرز معها العديد
من الاسئله المتعلقه بمستقبله السياسي
اهمها اذا كان لا يزال بامكانه اكمال
مشواره لمقعد الرئاسه مجددا وهو امر جائز
من الناحيه القانونيه فلا مانع من ترشح
ترامب حتى لو تمت ادانته لانه ببساطه
يمتلك المؤهلات الثلاث لمنصب الرئيس
ترامب من مواليد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يقل عمره عن 35 عاما اقام في
الولايات المتحده لمده 14 سنه متواصله على
الاقل
الاهم من تلك الشروط هو ان الدستور
الامريكي لا يمنع اي شخص مدان او لديه سجل
اجرامي من الترشح لرئاسه البلاد ما يعني
انه في حال تم اعتقال ترامب فسيستطيع
اكمال واداره حملاته وهو بداخل الزنزانته
بحسب لكن المشكله تظهر اذا فاز فعلا
فانتخاب رئيس لا يلغي التهم المرفوعه ضده
كما ان المنصب لا يخرجه من السجن في حال
الحكم بادانه ترامب بعد فوزه بالانتخابات
فليس امامه الا ان يبقى في السجن او يدفع
غرامه للحصول على حكم بوقف التنفيذ وحينها
سيصبح اول رئيس امريكي يتعرض للادانه من
ناحيتها ترى مجله التايم الامريكيه عدم
وجود اجابه واضحه حتى الان لما سيحدث حال
ادانه ترامب قبل او بعد فوزه بالانتخابات
ولا يعرف احد مصير القضايا المرفوعه ضده
لكن المؤكد هو ان الولايات المتحده قد
تواجه ازمه دستوريه على اعلى مستوى